well this is a large city uh uh 50 000
or so people live here
the river mers is behind me which is the
river that caused all of that trouble
i'll let you have a look at it you can
see the kind of mess behind me
this road and bridge closed it was this
river
that rose some 10 meters or so
from the level you see here just two or
three days ago
and caused absolute chaos as it pushed
through these streets turning the
streets themselves into rivers so
i'll give you a little snapshot of just
one street
there is nothing to do in this town
right now but clean up here you have a
family
pulling belongings out of their homes
it's muddy it's hot now obviously it's
summer
and um it's hard work
there's a bit of a sense of humor still
but uh
you can see that that's really very
difficult
there's an even a lady here who's had to
pull her
animal out of a home and look after it
you can have a look lex in here there's
a
there's a cat inside this uh this basket
struggling a little bit with the heat
very difficult for animals to um
to uh get themselves situated in in
places like this so we've seen dogs and
cats
struggling a little bit as homeowners
try and sort out
their own homes just a little look at
this
street area here this is why
infrastructure
has been such an issue and why thoughts
have turned really to
how fragile our modern lives are in the
face of such powerful water in
particular
this is the cabling of the town
underneath the pavement
internet connection and so on there is
no power
there is no water uh there's no cabled
internet
uh in some cases there's no fresh water
and people are struggling to get access
uh to food is being delivered of course
by lots of volunteers who are turning up
in natural disasters you often see the
best of people
and there's it's difficult to access
food because we've been into businesses
and supermarkets
you know nearby food supplies that have
been completely devastated
we met one owner of a supermarket who
said it was his life's work his life
savings
and it's finished he just can't see a
way even with insurance payouts for it
uh to be to be rescued and we'll just
continue to walk down this street
you bear with me i think our signal is
still holding up and you can see
just the piles and piles of stuff these
this sofas
and people's desks and children's books
we've got a microwave there
and you can see inside this home here
people trying to
uh to sort out their home
it's just been devastating meters and
meters of water
and now the cleanup
so okay hannah thank you so much further
down
i'm sorry kimberly we're struggling a
little bit with the with the signal but
you just got a snapshot here of just one
street in one town and how difficult it
has been for these people
to respond to this devastating event and
of course they're worried about when it
will happen
or what will happen when the waters come
again another time